what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and we just watched Moon
Knight episode 5. and boy did it tug on
our heartstrings hard a lot was revealed
in this to us but also to Stephen in
this episode now there is just a ton to
dissect in this episode so I'll
definitely be doing multiple breakdowns
on this episode including talking about
Easter eggs so in this episode let's
talk about some major things that happen
that are really important to not only
this episode but also to the finale
specifically how Mark Spector and
hopefully Steven Grant end up returning
so let's not waste any time let's dive
into it and of course if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest MCU videos now this
episode actually starts off in a cave
with a boy yelling help and then shows a
woman who says this is all your fault
now we obviously know that this is the
same with Mark's brother and then this
is his mom but we'll talk about that in
just a bit because after this it picks
up right where where the last episode
left off with towerette being introduced
and Mark and Steven freaking out however
instead of addressing who this
hippopotamus is right away we actually
cut back to the office of Dr Harrow
however this scene may not be what it
actually appears to be there are a
couple of details here that you really
need to look at one is that Mark seems
to have a busted nose he did not have
this busted nose in the previous scenes
where he is in the office of Dr Harrow
talking to him also his demeanor seems
to be a little bit different and he
actually doesn't talk that much until he
leans forward and says hey thank you I
feel really great he then grabs the
crystal pyramid like he's about to use
it as a weapon in which the doctor hits
the emergency button he has hidden that
signals the guards to come in he tries
to act cool but then when the guards
grab him he starts to yell you're gonna
release that monster you're not a doctor
now if you actually re-watch the scene
and listen very carefully this is not
the actual voice of Mark or Stephen
listen very carefully
great
I mean they always pay you a lot of
money in this place you're really good
did I tell you what I feel like a
million dollars never felt so good this
seems to be a completely different
person he also doesn't have the same
demeanor as Mark or Steven this is most
likely the personality of Jake lockley
now we were expecting a big reveal of
Jake this episode but we might not
actually get a huge reveal but may
actually just get little hints like this
scene right here we know that the Jake
lockley personality does exist because
in episode three it looked like Mark or
Steven killed some people but when Mark
takes control of the body and finds a
knife that he's holding is stabbed into
a person he looks around and says
Stephen what did you do in which Steven
says I didn't do that and Mark says I
didn't either thus confirming a third
personality inside of the body this is
much like the comics in the comics we do
have three personalities we have Mark
Spector Stephen Grant and Jake lockley
now obviously things are a little bit
different than in the comics in the
comic Steven Grant is a millionaire he
is the personality that funds all of
moon Knight's crime fighting and he's a
Playboy so not really like the Stephen
Grant that we know in the Moon Knight
series then there's Mark Spector who in
the comics is a mercenary but then there
is Jake lockley a smart cab driver and
this Persona is used to gather Intel
from the streets now since they changed
Stephen Grant from the comics they most
likely are going to change Jake lockley
as well and I think Jake lockley is
coming out when Mark and Steven are
super threatened and he's the one that
kills for example notice how he goes for
the crystal pyramid here he's ready to
use it as a weapon he is ready to kill
so in this scene right here I actually
think we are looking at Jake lockley and
the bandage is another giveaway that
this that is all happening right here
actually isn't real it is part of the
duet or the afterlife and this is just
something that is going on in his head
because in this scene right before this
his nose was not bandaged and now all of
a sudden it is and this is because it's
a different person it's Jake but then
right away the next scene we go back to
the hippo towerette and she confirms
that they are in the duot the Egyptian
underworld and that hippo is indeed the
goddess Tower the goddess of women and
children and also the goddess who helps
guide Souls through the afterlife Steven
being the somewhat scholar that he is
automatically knows who she is and
realizes what is happening and is
actually in shock he says wow out of
excitement now something that is really
really interesting here is that
towerette says that this is an afterlife
not the afterlife she confirms that
there are actually different Realms of
the afterlife so not all people go to
the same realm of an afterlife when they
die and she actually mentions the
ancestral planes and she says just
gorgeous these are the ancestral planes
from Black Panther so this would be the
afterlife for the wakandan people yet
again another reference to Black Panther
remember the Egyptian goddess Bast is a
part of the iniad and we saw a statue of
her in episode 3 but she mentioned
something very important here she says
you'd be surprised how many
intersectional planes of untethered
Consciousness exist what this basically
implies is that this is kind of based on
the mind of the person that has died so
whatever afterlife you go to is pretty
much based on your mind and in the sake
of Mark and Steven it's an asylum and as
towerette explains you may perceive the
afterlife as something more easily
recognizable to yourself so to Mark and
Stephen it's an asylum because as Mark
says they're crazy although there really
aren't because Mark opens the door which
leads to the afterlife and towerette's
boat is taking them to essentially
judgment Steven says we're going to the
field of reads right and the field of
reads is essentially heaven but
towerette says that they kind of have to
be judged first their hearts have to be
weighed and towerette puts their hearts
on the scale of Justice now if you
notice the statue in the middle is of
Anubis an ancient Egyptian believes
Anubis the god of the Dead measured the
hearts of the Dead on the scale of
Justice weighing them against the
feather of ma'at the God of Justice now
in ancient Egyptian beliefs if the heart
was lighter than the feather the soul
could go on to live forever in the
afterlife in the field of reeds now in
the MCU in this story the scales have to
be balanced it's also worth noting that
if your heart was not lighter than a
feather you essentially went to hell and
Amit the Goddess that Hera was trying to
resurrect ate your heart now Stephen
mentioned something very important here
when he's explaining to Mark what
taurette is doing he says she's weighing
their hearts on the scales of Justice
because the Egyptians believed that the
heart was the sign of who you really
were in life and this is very
interesting because she takes both of
their hearts even though there actually
is only one physical body there were
actually two people in that body because
as we saw Mark created Stephen very very
early on in life he looked to be around
maybe 10 years old so you would have to
weigh the heart of Steven and Mark to
truly tell who the person was in life
because there were two people this could
also be another saying that Jake really
doesn't come out that often and maybe
has only recently started to come out
now the hearts are on the scales but
towerette says there's a problem the
scales aren't balancing she says the
reason is is because their hearts aren't
full they're hiding something from each
other and the boat contains all of their
life's memories so they need to go
inside and work it out no more secrets
now here's where we discover a few
things one is when they go into a room
they see basically zombies they see dead
people and what this is is a room of all
of the people that Mark killed when he
was a mercenary and he even remembers
killing each one of them Steven says and
you remember all of them and Mark says
you try taking a life obviously implying
that it's a pretty big impact on
yourself when you kill somebody else
definitely not something you forget
however there's a little boy in the room
and Mark recognizes him but Steven
doesn't and Mark tries to get Stephen
not to go after him but Steven does and
locks Mark out of a room when Steven
goes in he sees his mother his father
himself and a brother that he didn't
know he had we obviously know that
Steven never knew of the brother because
Steven was created after his brother
died of course more on that in a bit but
in this scene right here Mark and his
brother roro decide not to eat but go
play in a cave before they leave Mark's
mother says be sure to look after your
brother okay Mark says yeah then he says
the classic late as gate is that we
actually hear Stephen say and his mom
then says in a while crocodile now sadly
it starts raining which makes the cave
pretty dangerous and water starts coming
up from the bottom and sadly Mark's
brother roro dies this in turn causes
his mother to absolutely hate him and
blame him for the death of his brother
and she pretty much makes his life a
living hell since then as if it wasn't
hard enough dealing with the death of a
brother now he eventually cut to a scene
where Mark is running away from home his
dad asked him to stay but he leaves
anyways which is where Mark and the
unconscious afterlife tackles Steven and
this actually brings them to the
original Moon Knight origin story from
the comics we've talked about this a lot
here and we finally have got it and we
find out what actually happened to
Layla's father the full story Mark even
explains that he was in the military
before but got discharged because he
went AWOL in a Fugue State now AWOL
means that you left without official
leave and a Fugue State refers to
dissociative Fugue which basically means
Mark was in the military but then
Stephen or perhaps Jake lockley came out
and left the military you're obviously
under contract and you can't just leave
the military so this got him discharged
so the only work he could get after he
was discharged was that of a contractor
a mercenary and here he explains that he
was on a site in Egypt with an old
partner Bushman this is Bushman from the
original comic story and just like in
the comics Bushman decides that he's
going to change the plan and instead
he's gonna actually kill everybody so
there's no Witnesses unfortunately this
did mean killing Layla's father Dr El
Foley but much like in the comics Mark
stands up to Bushman and fights him
however Bushman wins but right before
Mark dies he crawls to a statue of punch
you and he's about to end his life but
then kanchu reaches out to him and he
makes him a deal he can live or die but
if he lives he becomes conscious fist of
Vengeance his Moon Knight now in the
comics Mark actually dies and kanji
brings him back to life here it looks
like Mark doesn't actually die but we do
find out that kanchu really has been
manipulating mark because of his
so-called broken mind and that is the
origin story of Moon Knight in the MCU
and you gotta give it to Marvel Studios
with their comic accurate shots in the
MCU they are beautiful but then we go
back to towerette and her boat and as
they sail through the underworld
taurette notices that souls are being
judged before condemned to the Sands
before their time meaning they're not
dead they haven't died and then it's
their time to be judged they're actually
being judged while they're alive and we
of course know that this is what hero is
doing him and Amit are judging people
way before its third time and tauritt
says oh this is bad this is evil which
is the perfect time for Mark and Steven
to plead their case they need to get
back so they can stop Harrow and omit
however there is a problem if she sends
them back they're just gonna go back
into the same body that was shot that
died so they can't really go back
because they're essentially just gonna
die again but the answer to this problem
is conchu if konshu is brought back then
he can give Mark and Steven the Moon
Knight suit which would heal them but
then Steven says something very very
important he asked towerette if she can
send word to Layla to help free konchu
that way towerette can send them back to
a healed body and after asking if they
really want to go back with konshu they
say yes because it's the only way but
there are two problems one is that the
scale still aren't balanced which means
they could still be stuck in the
Underworld and two they have to go
through Osiris's gates to get back so
tavarette steers her ship towards
Osiris's Gates but she tells Mark and
Steven to go back inside and reveal
these hidden things and now we know what
the big secret was the big secret was
that Steven is actually the Persona the
identity that is made up Mark is the
main person and Steven is the identity
that sometime takes over this is
revealed in a scene where Mark is not
wanting to deal with his mother she is
banging on his door trying to break
through because she's about to punish
him and we see Mark bring Stephen to
life and he explains that he brought
Steven to life because Steven was the
part of him that was supposed to be
happy and carefree and not have to worry
about life and his mother and his
brother dying but then there's also
another major reveal which is the fact
that Mark's mother Steven's mother is
dead which makes you really wonder who
exactly was he talking to on the phone
this whole time now Steven could have
simply been leaving his mother
voicemails but in some of the episodes
it did seem like she was replying to him
even in the scene after the funeral of
his mother it does appear like Stephen
is talking to somebody Mark sits outside
of a house where people are gathered to
mourn the loss of his mother he says
it's a Shiva which is a Jewish week-long
morning period and Mark is Jewish he
decides not to go in even after he sees
his father and his father tells him to
come in he simply walks away now ashiva
is supposed to be a time where a person
Embraces and discusses their loss but
Mark doesn't want to deal with that
that's actually why he invented Stephen
and brought Stephen to life so instead
of dealing with it Steven comes out and
he has no idea where he is he simply
says oh I did it again and what he
thinks it is is just he's getting up at
night and essentially sleepwalking but
he pulls out the phone and it looks like
he is talking to somebody and it sounds
like there is a tiny back and forth he
even goes at one point in time no I know
I did it again like he is reacting to
something somebody is saying but we know
it's not his mom because his mother is
dead now I actually think that he could
simply be talking to himself and maybe
perhaps he is hearing a voice inside of
his mind because if you take a look at
his phone in this scene it's not
actually calling anybody it looks like
it's just kind of on a home screen and
in a show where we're dealing with
mental illness this probably makes sense
that it's kind of in his head which in
turn makes it even more sad now they
returned to the top of the ship where
unfortunately the scales aren't balanced
yet and towerette says she's sorry but
the underworld is essentially going to
claim them theirs and this is where we
actually see people that Marcus killed
before come onto the ship to try and
take him to the underworld and make him
a permanent part they're a little too
much for Mark to handle but Steven
realizes that if Mark can handle it so
can he they're the same person and
Steven steps up and he saves the day but
unfortunately it costs him his own life
and what's really interesting is that
after he gets taken by the Underworld
the scales balance now this is really
deep here what this most likely has to
do with is Mark facing his past he used
Steven to cope us so much in life but
now he can no longer use Steven the rest
of his journey is something that he has
to do on his own and now that Stephen
has sacrificed himself for Mark and Mark
has to go on a loan the scales are
balanced everything is out in the open
Stephen knows that he was the person
that has been made up Mark knows that he
created Stephen to deal with things that
he didn't want to deal with so he could
kind of ignore them and just be happy as
Steven but now he's faced all of that
and is on his own and he quickly finds
himself in the field of reeds basically
heaven and for somebody who's found
himself in heaven he doesn't look too
thrilled and of course that is because
he lost Stephen and Ahmed is about to
kind of take over the world and judge
millions of people before they even do
anything wrong now what is exactly going
to happen in the finale well towerette
even though she was nowhere to be seen
in the field of reads was steering her
ship towards the gates of Osiris which
is where she said they could return from
we also know that Tower it is going to
give a message to Layla to save konchu
so I'm guessing that all of this is
going to go down in the finale Layla is
going to be the one who frees konshu
then towerette is going to take Mark out
of the field of reeds by his own choice
through the gates of Osiris and back to
the Earthly plane she'll use her goddess
powers to put him back inside of his
body that was once dead once he's back
in that body konchu will summon the Moon
Knight suit which will heal the body and
from there on out Mark will go and try
to stop Harrow and which will have a
pretty epic fight scene one that has
been showed in a trailer TV spot of Mark
as Moon Knight running up a pyramid
while Arthur runs up the other side as
well so get ready for an epic final
battle but of course the big question is
is Stephen gone I do not believe so I do
think that he will return sadly he may
not return until after Mark battles Haro
but Mark Spector have an associative
identity disorder is a huge part of who
the character is you can't just have
Steven go away that takes away the
character so I am guessing that he is
going to return but they certainly did
pull on our heartstrings in this episode
because let's face it everybody loves
Steven Mark is awesome Moon Knight is
awesome Mr Knight is awesome but we all
love Steven Grant but let me know if you
think we'll see him again in the finale
in the comments down below and be sure
to let me know what you rate this
episode in the comments down below as
well I want to know what you think don't
forget to like the video and of course
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU videos for live
updates you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof